[Music]
it is the most fundamental experience of
all defining our waking moments and
giving rise to all that we think and
feel
without consciousness we have no way of
proving we or anything else exists and
yet what it is and why we have it remain
a mystery that some of the greatest
minds have been unable to solve the only
way I know I exist is because I'm
conscious I wake up in the dark of a
hotel room
I'm discombobulated because I'm
jet-lagged I've no idea where I am Who I
am and what country I am yet I know I
exist because I see something
rapid advances in our understanding of
how the brain works might one day allow
us to pinpoint the parts of the brain
that generate consciousness but will
something as objective as science be
able to explain what it feels like to be
us consciousness - nature is private
it's subjective I know about my
consciousness from the first-person
point of view other people don't know
about my consciousness very indirectly
philosophers have been trying to answer
some of these questions for millennia in
the past couple of centuries scientists
have joined them debate can be fierce in
fact some scholars reckon the puzzle of
consciousness is something that human
mind is incapable of solving I think
that's not just wrong I think it's it's
culpably wrong it isn't impossible at
all it's just that we have to buckle
down and do it
one thing that both disciplines can
agree on is that consciousness arises in
the brain
made up of roughly 85 billion neurons
and other supporting cells about which
we know little the brain consumes almost
20 percent of our energy despite
comprising just 2% of our mass every so
often I get kind of interested in
astronomy and cosmology because you look
out there and you think oh gosh this is
amazing you know it's almost limitless
but then I turn around and kind of
introspective and think about the brain
and it's kind of like a universe within
we're a long ways of understanding how
it works but if we can get down to
figuring out how a neuron works by God
then we could deal with it two neurons
and then four neurons and four million
neurons and then a hundred million
helped by developments in imaging partly
pioneered by dr. reichal and his team
scientists can study in some detail the
two enormous folded sheets of out of
rain called the cerebral cortex this
plays a crucial role in higher brain
functions like memory perception thought
and language and I have two of them in
my left hand height and and it's part of
this sheet that gives eyes to
consciousness this sheet also give rise
to intelligence and reasoning and all
the other things that we hold dear but
the what the human brain in the human
mind Christophe Kok wants to come up
with a satisfactory scientific theory of
consciousness before he dies science
wants to explain everything if if
science fails to explain the central
fact of my existence I would say then
it's a it's it's a failure in order to
gain a better understanding of how parts
of the brain work scientists often look
at bits of it that are broken it's a
little part of the brain called the
cerebellum which is at the back of my
brain if I lose it I will be unable to
let's say to dance or beer or climb and
her difficulty moving my speech becomes
slurred but my consciousness will not be
impaired on the flip side it seems that
some parts of the brain may be essential
for consciousness identifying these so
called neural correlates of
consciousness would help pin down what
is happening what might the NCC the
neural correlates of consciousness be
like assuming that it is that it's an
emergent and neuro scientific
and let me say straight away that we
don't know was his life before his death
in 2004 Francis Crick the co-discoverer
of the structure of DNA worked with dr.
[ __ ] on something they termed the
binding problem put simply the binding
problem asks how the brain integrates
different bits of information it gets
both sensory and internal into our
conscious experience in real life the
brain is terribly good and puts
everything together the movement the
shape and and the color the usual way of
saying the binding problem is if you
have a red square and a green triangle
how is it that you don't have see it as
that get the colors mixed up with the
shapes that's basically the problem
because our experience of consciousness
is derived from the data we get from
lots of different systems the visual and
motor being just two the two men looked
at a part of the brain that is connected
to all these regions they were
especially interested in the claustrum a
thin sheet of nerve cells that sits at
the bottom of the cerebral cortex in
each hemisphere of the brain because
testing the claustrum in a live human
brain is invasive and risky no formal
experiments have been done but one
happened accidentally last year when a
neurologist trying to understand the
source of his patient's epilepsy
implanted electrodes near her claustro
when he switched the current on she lost
consciousness as soon as he switched it
off she regained it no one knows why we
have consciousness it's one of the big
mysteries why did evolution bother
putting consciousness in how did
evolution put consciousness in why
couldn't we have done everything that we
do with a set of objective mechanisms
and no first-person subjective
experience of the world it's one of the
biggest questions and philosophy in
science just as the processes of
consciousness remain a mystery so does
its purpose is it a high-level summary
the brain generates to help us plan for
what comes next a clever way of
designing our brains to make us more
adept at being social neither both
one evolutionary explanation for why we
have consciousness suggested an animal
capable of modeling the behavior of
another can anticipate it to its
advantage the surprising thing is that
so few animals actually have this
ability humans have it so I have a very
good idea of what you're going to do and
when you're going to do it and why
you're going to do it and children
starting it maybe around three years old
get that Janet Metcalf the theory of
mind a theory of mind is actually
misnomer the way we tested is whether a
person or an animal can give evidence
that they can get into the other
person's shoes or the other person's
mind and see the world from that
person's perspective now the the test of
it is often not just can you see from
the viewpoint of the other person but
could you see that someone has a
different viewpoint from your own the
theory of mind might provide one way of
working out if animals other than humans
are conscious the only species that
we're absolutely sure has theory of mind
is human and maybe humans older than
roughly three years old it's very
controversial whether any other animals
have it they're arguing about whether
chimps have theory of mind or not before
we can have a theory of mind we must
recognize ourselves for decades
scientists have used something called
the Rouge test to see whether animals do
just that
human babies do from about eighteen
months old chimpanzees presented with
mirrors soon use them to groom
themselves much as we do elephants
dolphins and Magpies also can respond to
mirrors in ways that suggest self
recognition the problem with the roush
test that the animal researchers always
raise is that maybe there it's just body
knowledge that it's not mind knowledge
so it was interpreted as the animal
knowing that they have a mind and theory
of mind as we normally think
that is related to another person not to
the self but presumably you have to know
that you have a mind before you project
that same capability onto someone else
identifying the neural correlates of
self recognition in animals would be a
hard task but if we were able to do it
comparative studies would be possible
that would be hugely valuable science is
edging closer to understanding what
parts of the brain might be involved in
generating conscious experience by some
estimates we may not be far away from an
empirically sound theory of
consciousness and how it evolved but
could a physical theory ever
satisfactorily address what it is that
people are feeling when they are
conscious David Chalmers calls
consciousness the hard problem a deft
description for something that is hard
to explain and hard to solve the methods
of science right now are great for
explaining objective processes and
objective functions so when it comes
even to explaining things like the
behavior of an organism you can tell
some story about a bit of the brain a
neural process or a computer leg process
in the brain that makes us behave a
certain way but the problem of
consciousness what we call the hard
problem of consciousness which is
explaining how you get subjective
experience from the brain is not that
kind of question
[Music]
it's not a question about how we behave
it's a question about you know what it's
like about how it feels from the inside
and looks like you can explain all those
objective mechanisms and objective
processes and you still won't have
answered the hard problem which is why
is it that all that functioning is
accompanied by consciousness the hard
problem divides philosophers and
scientists alike some philosophers argue
that consciousness can be explained far
more simply a lot of puzzles Bell
mysteries we're going to understand it
from the bottom up and from the top down
I have no doubt about that Daniel
Dennett argues that consciousness is
nothing more than a cognitive illusion
that science will into course explain
our brains have been designed by
evolution and then redesigned by
cultural evolution to give us a
user-friendly system of things in the
world that we deal with so the
user-friendly world that we live in the
manifest image is a sort of friendly
user illusion in the same way that the
desktop of your laptop is a user
illusion it simplifies and it distorts
in helpful ways for most purposes if you
really want to know what's going on you
have to go backstage and the same thing
is true about the bay
[Music]
until recently we didn't have very good
tools for doing it the brain was just
off limits as off-limits as distant
galaxies we're now developing the tools
for non-invasively studying the brain
and we're now developing the
computational ideas and models so that
we can understand how a brain can non
miraculously deal with information and
refine it and uncover the semantics of
the world or outside and inside so we're
now we now have the toolkit and it's
taken this long to develop it now we
just have to use the tools perhaps but
for the time being the puzzle of
consciousness continues to pose more
questions than it does answers yet
another philosopher Pythagoras of Abdera
proclaimed that man is the measure of
all things until the problem of
consciousness is solved though that
might better be phrased the measure of
all things but himself
[Music]